hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I'm watching the green my my gosh he has
a mouse I want a rat so bad a pet rat I
think I've talked about that too much on
this series I think I've mentioned my
need for a pet rat like eight or nine
times moving on it looks like it's about
a wrongful accusing of someone and then
hopefully like it's a feel-good
tearjerker
Kanna deal uplifting story of guards and
captives husbands and wives prisoners
and a mouse named mr. jingles
oh I mean my best green attire this wig
that was three dollars and then my green
onesie from when I was a claw rock so I
think I'm ready to go how about you
let's do it
[Music]
was that don't get me wrong yes it was
an incredible movie full of more heart
than any movie deserves but what the was
that was not feel good there were some
good moments but that was feel bad you
watch three people who get the chair
there's where do the magic come from
where is that okay I didn't realize it
was Stephen King fine
sue me where the hell did that magic
come from what oh my god I just I guess
it's the length at which the public
executions happens that really got me
it's there are people at these things I
didn't realize I don't think that's how
it is today is it do people go to
executions of people no writes me at the
death sentence no right no right the
only thing that got me through the only
thing and let me be clear the only thing
and let just one more time the only
thing that got me through was mr.
jingles the movie opens on a search for
two girls uh-oh the movie though it
doesn't open on that I guess it opens on
Tom Hanks character in an old folks home
having kind of a mental breakdown and
his friend comes up who definitely wants
to bang him and is like I want to help
you man what's going on well let me tell
ya it was the year something something
something and I had the worst urinary
tract infection of my life you gotta
love a man who starts a story like that
there's so much to this story there's
literal magic
he's like well I remember it fondly
because my penis hurt real good it's
kind of a notebook style telling which I
realized that the notebook came way
after and is also not nearly as good as
Green Mile but it reminded me of that
because I've seen the notebook and I
hadn't seen this the notebook doesn't
even have magic so and this I still
really thought that it was just a
wrongful conviction like they were gonna
find John coffees character John coffee
is the character they were gonna find
John coffee and
and he was gonna be wrongfully accused a
minute at the end it was gonna be
revealed that he didn't do it and then
he gets to go free and then him and mr.
jingles live forever together they find
John Coffey with the two girls in his
hands and he sobbing he's like I
couldn't make it right I I wanted to
take it back but I couldn't in your like
oh well maybe he did do it then he goes
into the prison and we meet Percy who
just loves his job being the Groot of
saying dead man walking dead man walking
dead we know Percy we get it thank you
very much chef thank you boo I just
gotta say Percy I love love villains
like that I mean I hate him with every
fiber of my being but that actor crushed
it he's that kind of character in this
kind of movie where you know he's gonna
do something so seemingly bad and then
you know what's coming to him is gonna
come to him but like it doesn't come
soon enough that something so so so bad
happens that you just can't even believe
anyone could move on from it kind of
deal you know I mean you know me there
and so that's Percy's character in this
and true to form that's what happened so
the first execution that you see that's
where they're in their own death room I
don't know why I didn't realize I was
gonna be seeing any executions here the
first one you see is this Native
American prisoner you don't ever find
out what he did it was so uncomfortable
how long it went on and Percy's just
about to think cream his little shorts
over there on the side because he wants
to be up front and personal with the
execution back to the urinary tract
infection he's such a good actor he's
been struggling with this forever he's
always like sweaty and uncomfortable and
sad and there's one scene where he wakes
up and he used to run outside to the
outhouses there's no plumbing in the
house at the he lives in with his wife
and he's running outside he doesn't make
it to the outhouse and he's like falls
to his knees and in such seething pain
he's like you you see the pee habit and
his face is just like struggling it's
hard to imagine being asked to do that
and just delivering such a believable
good see John Coffey has been in this
prison hasn't said much at all
John Coffey grabs his penis some light
comes from it and then he starts
coughing he coughs up like gnats bees
locusts what I don't know what he's
coughing it he's coughing up some kind
of magic bugs and then he goes and he
has sex with his wife four times and
apparently it's good she's feeling good
because it don't work the next morning
he breathes in freshly baked cornbread
from his wife from John Coffey as a
thank you so weird so wonderful but not
at all where I expected this story to go
in the least bit not knowing it was
Stephen King
I just went what is happening right now
the next the next thing I wrote is Percy
the goddamn piece of it's not done
mr. jingles the mouse a lot happen in
between there but it's just like so much
story building so much character
building and so master copies like give
me that now he brings mr. jingles back
to life uh so Dell the inmate that I and
everyone else grows to love who has mr.
jingles who befriends this amazing
little prison rat it's his time to die
so because they want Percy outs they let
him be up in front for Adele's execution
[Music]
Percy doesn't wet the sponge which is a
very crucial step ends then so the
electricity is just frying him to death
it went on for a long time and you're
seeing this guy that you've grown to
love suffering and they're like should
we turn it off what do we do when
they're like wall we can't turn it off
now he's still alive and we turn it off
he's just no cuz then what do know so
you find out that Tom's boss has a wife
and she has a brain tumor
so they just want to add another fun sad
thing to this that's fun I'm glad I'm
just glad that they keep piling it on
silly one John Coffey to heal her John
Coffey is kind of like a way more
powerful CEO from Hill House they get
out of the prison eventually they take
him to the white he heals her and
usually he cops up B's in a horrific
manner and he doesn't them up and
you're like okay well he's chosen to
keep the brain tumor and die this way I
guess versus the electric chair which I
guess I feel if that was an option
I guess never been in that situation
before he pukes the NAT be Lukas's into
Percy's mouth and then he ends up in a
mental ward do you want to know what job
he was gonna transfer to working at the
vets award bitches yeah
I knew I was coming you have to have
some kind of like arc of destruction for
such a terrible character but I'm glad
it was such an arc of such destruction I
just I love movies that are so realistic
so plausible so heavy in the way that
real life is and then it's just got this
one magic ass aspect it's so flippin
good so tom hanks goes to John Coffey
and he's like what do you want me to do
because I will do it knowing that he's
innocent
and John copies like you know huh I'm
tired the world is terrible I have no
friends
I'm tired then Tom Hanks is like well
what can I do for you and he's like oh
my god just thinking about I was that
guy he's like I just want to see a movie
I've never seen a movie and so they take
him in to see the heaven I'm in heaven
movie and the way that he watches the
movie is so good that's when I lost it I
had gotten a little misty here and there
before the heavy movie it's hard it's
not even like a cry cry movie it's like
up until this point it's it's just like
it's hard to watch it
toilet sad but it's not I didn't cry
mama big crier but this part broke me
I've lost about this part he's just so
happy to watch it it's like did this one
dang moment of happiness for this
plagued character and then there's the
execution ugly crying like sobbing like
that kind of cry that gets something out
in you that you didn't even know you
were holding on to and then you just cry
it out this was just a liberating cry
and I wasn't ready for this movie to end
I was ready it's three hours long it's
so good but still three hours is three
hours at this point I'm like it can't it
can't end here he walks over to the
cottage and mr. t Hills is still alive
baby so happy it was like exactly what I
needed from this movie that was so
draining
I wondered let me know what you feel and
what you felt when seeing this movie but
did it affect you in the way that it
affected me I imagine so I mean this
really is it's hard to get through
overall I loved it and it was incredible
and not it what's gonna be I can't
believe after all these years that
things like this don't get ruined for me
thank you so much for watching I will
see you all next week
P he'll Tom Hanks Tom's Hanks penis
heading 1911 and my heart some something
something else
[Music]
[Applause]
you